you joke around a lot but I mean I love
your voice I love your voice I didn't
love your voice wait are you joking
around no I really do love your voice
John telling be insincere
oh yes tell him be insincere tell me
inauthentic your something being real
I want to opium like more videos with
you guys if people love you
then you can be in more videos people
love you it's all about the comments
it's all about the calm it's all about
obeying what other people want from you
that's why warning in tonight just
looking at comments looking at comments
he cares about his fans
I want my fans to know I obeyed anything
you guys request beyond my wants and
desires
she means a fan he now is here today
yeah that's right
brought a fan on the channel who's the
cool youtuber who's the cool you know um
all inclined oh my god don't hug me I'm
scared okay Jimmy my man Jimmy my
jimster Slim Jim don't hug me i'm scared
six i asked this guy before he came over
can you please watch john homie i'm
scared
1 through 5 took like an hour of his
life up it was worth it but at the same
time i was like why is it worth it
Oh Jimmy you're joking around with me
again I'll spank you
nope I don't believe in jokes my friend
really I believe in full sincerity and
authenticity of the key to good
communication
eight minutes eight minutes is it longer
than the other than the other few first
radio ad that something is pretty long
just wonder what might be longer they've
gotten better than this yeah don't talk
when they're talking
Oh jumbo he's sleeping okay here we go
she no how can you be sleepy if you
don't know how to have dreams are you
looking out I try I do what you do
oh you go No
like somebody's having a bad dream
Oh God
yeah this is cinema can you file these
files please I'm telling you again it's
like office space and white screen and
everything
Hey wouldn't it be funny but one of
these balls came alive yes I am a violin
you put documents in me mrs. dreaming
you know it didn't like it solo
that sounds really boring my dick
[ __ ] spaghetti
yeah they spaghetti bring the ring /
SpaghettiOs
I was so not
I'm in the ground
Osmond
yeah
I've seen Jason stay at the movie shop
as well
it's like a talent show talent show
your talent show I know you're a little
younger that make sure you try to want
to be the leader want to teach all right
how to live I septet Craig that's rude
man yes your braces in agile it's not
very good
poor fella
like to be in that position man in great
talent show
music to my bed what you say new you're
adorable
so happy you're here right now then this
video makes me sick time when you go
like history stop the power but into a
mystery you make me shine into me
yeah oh yeah are we doing the reviewing
this guy's been tortured whole time
whole times mr. Truman Show
all right he's trying to send a message
or something yeah they're trying to
force education onto us as children you
know but loud images sounds it's why we
can't read books pretty sure it's all
this information education in the
overload just priceless crazy don't love
me I'm scared make sense I mean watch to
do so for you like a timber and movie
sort of messages
that guy yeah
see but he wishes to live in the world
imagination because all he was was
programmed his whole life to be an adult
but he wants to be a kid again and he's
a kid being forced to dream out of work
huh so Sid so deep it all makes
now he's back
what's your favorite idea
did they just x-men Days of Future past
did that [ __ ] on us did you see that you
feel it go back to the pages already
started the whole timeline here they
restarted the timeline or they just
showed us how it all worked out
so dude who's trapped in there BAM oh my
gosh it's just a child being forced like
go to sleep when we want you to stay in
your room all this stuff about education
being thrown in your face with loud
images that's why we can't focus on
school that's not all these young kids
are getting diagnosed with things like
immediate ADHD I feel that right now I
feel that right yeah I'm still in high
school I feel we become addicted to it
that's why the spaghetti guy wanting to
be a kid again he lost in that
imagination it's the only time we felt
free was me really younger and allowed
to dream but then you took control of
our dreams adults baby boomers guys I
think I had made this video so
worthwhile
I think I've analyzed the [ __ ] out of
this video I mean do you have more
in-depth opinion than I do right now
I mean can you share one that's more
in-depth uh this is the best experience
I've had so far of them of that very
good very good
I love the effects that they have it it
like clearly you and you saw the first
one today yeah I love how they have
greatly taken advantage of the success
they've had and up their quality and up
their budget they started doing but once
where you're like those are clearly a
bunch of actors and those wearing the
masks and stuff they're actual actors
and I got the talent show and everything
so it's cool to see their ideas still
expanding in terms of how they filmed
their stuff I know when they did their
first view when they talked about it
they said that it was just like abstract
it's totally open to interpretation but
I feel like they're becoming more
specific that they have to become more
cohesive and they have to adapt it to
something more specific in order to keep
this alive you know or this is the end
who knows this could be the end of it
all this could be the last don't hug me
video I'm scared
it was just trying to send a message on
let's try to send a message and I get
the message finally
so what artists you
obviously you gotta be is you gotta be
as smart as me thank you
I'm admiring you yeah pretty good pretty
smart man well guys I hope this was
worth your time in my time in his time
and John's time it was totally off to
the side doing his own thing not being
attention at all if you're new to the
channel of the real the real the real
rejects sub scription services are
offered do it yeah Jimmy has a
SoundCloud account no music on there yet
it'll be there soon soon either
and it Alita Graham he has and he's so
attractive he's so nice so photogenic he
keeps telling that you're very
photogenic am i you're very photogenic
you see some pictures of me yeah what
are you joking again I just don't think
I should make a masturbation here is
there somewhere